endlich in freiheit toben bild besucht
heute die kleinen kühlschrank welpen im
tierheim in köln zollstock hier müssen
die sieben wochen alten malteser erst
einmal in die tollwut quarantäne und von
den pflegern ordentlich aufgepäppelt
werden
rückblick als die kölner polizei bei
einer wohnungsdurchsuchung den
kühlschrank öffnet bietet sich ihnen ein
schreckliches bild
die ermittler blicken in diese kleinen
welpen knopfaugen völlig verängstigt und
eingeklemmt zwischen den glasboden
hocken die vier malteser welpen im
kühlschrank in einer wohnung in
chorweiler versteckt von illegalen tier
händlern vor der polizei eine
grauenhafte tierquälerei insgesamt fünf
malteser und noch weitere welpen werden
mit hilfe des veterinäramtes befreit und
sofort ärztlich versorgt wie will man
sich von voller kot so die waren halt
sehr verschmutzt und wir müssen sie halt
jetzt fast jeden tag waschen
aber so langsam werden sie fitter und
erholen sich aber es gibt ein echtes
happy end aktuell geht es den kleinen
fellknäuel schon viel besser sie sind
wie video und treten mit ihren
geschwistern die mitarbeiter tauften die
malteser übrigens paula mali kuno pascal
und tilda das tierheim kann sich kaum
retten vor anfragen zu den süßen
vierbeiner aber die werden frühestens im
januar ein neues liebevolles zuhause
finden
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
weil bild schau dir hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren